bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you you're tuning in to
the Deen show you've come to the right
place
to learn about Islam and the Muslims and
we are going to be talking about love
everywhere you go love love love when
you want to get in religion it's all
about love Jesus love this love that
love what about Islam where's the love
and Islam is Allah the Creator about
love or is about striking fear in your
heart you might have been programmed to
believe something that's not true
so you've come to the Muslims to learn
about Islam and we're here to teach you
we want to thank you for having an open
heart and open mind so the topic of
today is Islam's message of love is
there really love in Islam is it all
about violence and blowing things up and
don't believe the hype so today all we
ask that you have an open heart open
mind we're going to come back with
former Christian minister Deacon
graduate from Harvard the prestigious
Harvard University dr. Gerald Dirk's
he's back on the Dean show to talk about
Islam and love here we'll be right back
salaam this is the danger
this is the thing
assalamu alaikum peace be with you and
with you brother how are you dr. Turks
very fine thank you very much it's a
pleasure to have you back here with us
here on the Deen show my pleasure now
you have your own private section at the
Deen show calm people can go and read
about your biography to learn more about
you and all the past shows that we've
done so we want to bring them up to
speed on that but we're gonna get in
straight to the topic love when people
they talk about religion Christianity
more so they attribute Christianity is
all about love just love this love that
doesn't matter just love it all so now
when people start to investigate and
they see like hey I'm not really digging
this whole Trinity thing things aren't
making sense dot God died in for my sins
and all that but the love thing is just
you know penetrated the heart so you
come over here and you you turn on TV
and things are blowing up here and there
and and the hype is promoting that Islam
is about violence there's no love in
Islam how far is this from the truth dr.
Dirk 180 degrees 180 degrees 180 degrees
from the truth you know there was an
email circular that went around mass
email a few years ago in which the claim
was made that Allah or God in His 99
names there's no word for love look and
in fact that's not true at all yes one
of the 99 names of God is our what dude
Allah dude our what dude which means the
loving and twice we have this in the
Quran in one point we're told ask your
Lord to forgive you and turn towards him
in repentance and obedience for my Lord
is full of forgiveness and loving
tenderness right in the Quran or another
example your Lord has a firm grip he
initiates creation and restores life to
the dead
the forgiving and loving the lord of the
throne of glory and doer of all that he
intends also from the quran so god is
the loving this is the message of islam
and it's a direct love a direct love
from god to his creation
there's no intermediary you know it's
direct God loves you over and over again
we're told in the Quran all the
different groups that God loves he loves
those who do good who are repentant and
pure who were mindful of him who love
Him and follow Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him who were good who patiently
persevere who trust in him these are all
the people that God loves he loves the
fair judges he loves those who are
mindful of their obligations he loves
those who make themselves pure all of
these specifically listed in the Quran
he loves those who were even-handed
those who were tolerant that's an awful
lot of love going on even those who
reject God he's still giving him the air
that they breathe the subsidence that
they need to survive yes yes and this
goes right into another of the 99 names
of God that we have in Islam which is
ar-rahman the merciful the compassionate
the compassionate and you know God is
called the compassionate about 167 times
in the Quran wow this is a message that
is repeated over and over and over again
and in fact there's a key verse in the
Quran that I think is worth reciting
which is from the 19th chapter of the
Quran and it's say to them if anyone
goes astray
that's anyone if anyone goes astray the
compassionate will hold out the Rope of
salvation to them up until the point
they see the promised destruction or the
coming of the
don't think about that a moment God is
the compassionate and if we go astray
and we're human we do all of us at times
God literally throws out the Rope of
salvation directly to us all we have to
do is grab hold of it
there's a saying of Prophet Mohammed
which also really brings into focus this
idea of God as a compassionate
Abdul Rahman bin Alfred reported that he
heard the Messenger of God peace be upon
him say god the exalted said I am
ar-rahman
that is the compassionate I created the
womb Brahm an Arabic womb and derived my
own name out of it now again you have to
stop and think about this for a moment
what is the womb you know for the fetus
it supplies everything that is needed it
supplies shelter supplies warmth it
supplies nourishment it supplies life
itself the one more time yes the morning
from the way absolutely yeah and God
takes his name the compassionate out of
that word mm-hmm you know God's
compassion is literally womb-like
encompassing us with everything that we
need now you definitely did your
homework before because you were a
former Christian Deacon he graduated
from the prestigious Harvard University
when you had a master's in divinity so
you knew the Bible well you know the
Bible well I mean you're a humble person
so you won't admit it but I mean we
consider you a Christian Bible scholar I
mean so you know the Bible well but now
to come over from religion which is
really emphasizing love and Jesus love
and now the hype is that Islam isn't but
you're giving the proof that it is you
did your homework mm-hmm you really I
mean you investigated obviously you
weren't led blindly just by your
emotions this was an intellectual
scientific decision that you made to
come to Islam yes it was just one of the
things that also led you to the mercy
and compassion of the creator of the
heavens and earth Allah I think it would
be very hard to accept a religion that
doesn't have yeah a loving God a
compassionate God a merciful God where
do you think people get this
misinformation now well I think there's
you know a fairly systematic attempt by
the media to portray Islam and they get
a fashion and I'm not saying they're
doing that because they're anti Islam
but the fact of the matter is having a
Muslim up on national media saying God
is love you know that's not gonna sell
any newspapers that's not going to
increase anybody's TV ratings having
some fringe case get up and say
something extremely controversial yeah
that sells newspapers that jacks up the
TV ratings yeah and so you know the
media simply doesn't give coverage to
mainstream Muslims who are sharing this
message yeah that you know Islam is the
religion of love God is the loving in
Islam yes yes this is a central message
of Islam God is the loving he is the
compassionate and he's also the merciful
on Raheem a third Arabic word here and
God has referred to in the Quran about
227 times as being the merciful for
example we have in the Quran then God
replied I bring my punishment to bear
upon whomever I want but my mercy
extends over all things i prescribed it
for those who are mindful of me who give
in charity and who believe
our signs that's from the seventh
chapter of the Quran god it's Marie
extends over all things let's take a
break there and we'll be right back with
more with dr. Gerald Dirk's here on the
Dean show
show us the way to all the squids this
is the D do you know this is the welcome
back to the Dean show we're talking with
dr. Gerald Dirk's former Christian dica
and minister finished from the
prestigious Harvard University and we're
talking about love and Islam's message
of when you look at the word Islam yes I
Islam is I am I shall love all mankind
I mean we all believe that you know
Islam believe you know we learn from the
creator of the heavens and earth Allah
the most loving and merciful that we are
all born in original goodness yes so we
don't have any hate we love every child
that comes into this world every human
being that's out there has a fresh start
but how do we balance it because I
really feel this is a cop-out now when
they push everything on the back of the
most beloved message you're one of the
most beloved messengers Jesus peace be
upon them and now people to indulge in
their transgression they just throw out
love and love and just no accountability
obviously in this time there is
accountability yeah it's not enough to
say I believe yeah you know we also have
to be responsible for our actions and
our behavior here on earth and in terms
of final judgment we certainly believe
as Muslims that you have to have the
correct belief that is belief in one God
but you also have to be accountable for
the deeds that you have done on earth in
fact there is a saying where we're told
that the sins that we commit in terms of
our relationship to God those sins God
will forgive if we are truly repentant
it's the sins we commit these of each
other that we need the forgiveness of
our fellow man you know we have to reach
out to them
asked for forgiveness and truly repent
yes and mend our ways so there is
accountability
but the third factor that defender
enters into this of course is God's
mercy hmm so we have proper belief you
know what sort of life did we live and
if those are the only two things on the
scale most of us would be in a lot of
trouble but the third thing we have is
God's mercy it's this overflowing mercy
the Quran tells us in Chapter two God is
kind and merciful to all people God's
mercy is there all we have to do is ask
for it but the thing is do do most
people I mean wanted God has manifested
his love and mercy to us but how many
people are actually running towards the
Creator because if you go to him a hand
span he comes to you an arm's length but
how many people are actually seeking him
out well I think and I'm speaking here
as is switch hats among to my former
profession in psychology I think there
is a deep spiritual yearning in people
definitely definitely you know and and
unfortunately sometimes they don't know
how to reach out to fill that spiritual
void but I think that void is is there
they're feeling it they're reaching out
definitely you know the rapid growth of
Islam in this country I think is one
example of that now a moment ago you
refer to a very important saying of the
Prophet peace be upon him which is that
God said if you come closer to me by a
span which is roughly from the thumb tip
to the little fingertip I'll come closer
to you by a cubit which is elbow to top
of fingers about 18s yes and if you come
closer to me by a cubit
I'll come closer to you by two
outstretched arms and if you come to me
walking I'll come to you running this
the love the compassion the mercy of God
that is to be found in Islam and again I
want to emphasize this is a direct love
from God to each individual person it's
a direct compassion from God to each
individual person direct mercy from God
to each individual person you know for
God to love us to be compassionate to us
to be merciful to us Aslam says there's
no need for some sort of blood sacrifice
on a cross you know this is love and
mercy and compassion that God freely
gives to us and to receive God's
forgiveness for whatever we've done all
we need to do is repent tell us how do
we balance out because if we look back
to the Bible and I used to drive down
one Street and a head on the bench it
was a Bible for a quote from Proverbs I
believe what says fearing God is the
beginning of wisdom
sure now how do we balance it out
because God Almighty as you have quoted
with all the evidence that he is a God
of mercy and love and at the same time
how does someone when they read you know
having God consciousness and also being
fearful of doing evil actions sure how
do we balance this out would you say
well I think we have to remember that in
Islam
we're told God has 99 names or
attributes you know we've been talking
about three of them our dude
the loving ar-rahman the compassionate
honor Haim the merciful and touched
briefly on a fourth one which is goddess
forgiveness or the forgiving but God is
more than that you know there are the
other names as well God is justice and
we have to bear that in mind simply
saying I believe is not an automatic
pathway to heaven
in Oslo you got a talk is cheap yeah
that's right you have to walk the walk
walk the walk the walk yeah and it's
like kind of like the carrot and the
stick
mm-hmm can you can make that compare
there's the reward but now for the
person who wants to maybe go ahead and
hurt somebody an innocent person yeah
he's got a fear the consequence on the
day of judgement report so that's that
complete balance in the scam does the
love God is willing to accept you he's
the most loving but don't you go near
hurting other individuals and committing
great transgression in the land that's a
complete balance in this life doesn't it
yeah there is that balance but again I
do want to emphasize you know if you
step over the line yeah he's still he's
still there for you still there for you
you know but you have to repent you got
a you know you you have to repent yeah
and you have to make the effort to mend
your ways mm-hmm it has to be sincere
repentance yeah so I can't just go smack
someone in the face say you know I'm
sorry then come back smack him again
I you have to make the effort to change
your weather change my ways I'm stealing
stop stealing that's right
so I'm committing transgression against
people backbiting whatever I got a
change and mend my ways become a better
person isn't it and that's what God
Almighty wants so this is me this makes
sense continue please share some more
with us about the loving and merciful
creator of the heavens and earth alone
well you know a concept that we just
briefly touched on as God as the
forgiving and we're told this
approximately 87 times in the Quran that
God is the forgiving for example in the
sixth chapter of the Quran were told
your Lord has written it upon his own
nature to be merciful so if any of you
did evil deeds and ignorance but then
repented and improved your conduct then
he is forgiving and merciful so
forgiveness is there for anyone who
seeks it but again one has to that has
to be an honest repentance an honest
repentance it's not enough to simply say
I believe
yeah and here we can make a contrast
with at least certain modes of
Christianity yeah
in certain modes of Christianity belief
is it boom
you know salvation by faith really
doesn't matter what you do but once you
accept then you're saved yeah but I want
to stress this with certain modes of
Christianity not all versions of
Christianity before we're going to break
this there's a wonderful saying of the
last and final messenger authentic
hadith just showing that God Almighty I
mean to also add to what you said like
if you make a mistake you come back to
God it even so much so if your sins were
to reach the heavens and the earth now
how many of us can't acquire that many
say that's a lot of sins but there's a
condition of stipulation not setting up
partners with the guy the one God not
calling out his creation some people
they call on mighty messengers you know
such as Jesus peace be upon him or icons
and statues now this is a big no-no so
you can have committed all these sins
you turn to God and you repent but not
setting up another God next to God can
you just elaborate upon this for a
second
only again as I said before there in
Islam there's really three components
that we look at in terms of salvation
one is proper belief yeah and of course
this means pure monotheism pure
monotheism one God one God only the
second aspect is proper behavior and
conduct not just in terms of our
relationship with God but also in terms
of our relationship with our fellow man
yes and the third aspect then that enter
sin is of course God's abundant mercy
definitely we'll be right back with more
here on the Deen show
it's a way of life or to us bad the
messenger best of man can show us the
way to Alyce quiz this is the Dean Dean
Addison this is the Dean Dean of ease
back here on the Dean show we're talking
to dr. Gerald Dirk's
and we're talking about the love and
mercy that islam teaches preachers and
is there for anyone who is seeking to
get closer to the creator of the heavens
and earth there's one hadith that also
comes to my mind of the mercy of the
Creator one and I'm sure you know this
went when a woman had had had lost her
child
and she found him and she started to
suckle the child the problem I said look
at that said God Almighty he has more
love for his lazy for more love for you
than this mother who is suckling her
child
yes what do you say about that uh-hum to
Lilith this is the Islam's message of
love yeah in a nutshell
there's also had beef saying of the
Prophet where we're told that with God
there were 100 parts of Mercy yes and
one of those 100 parts was bestowed upon
all of creation the other 99 parts
remaining with God was time to think
about this if you were to tally up every
act of mercy
that has ever been done by any person
animal etc throughout all of creation
and extending on until the end of
creation that would only be 199th
the amount of Mercy that God is holding
to bestow upon us how would you
encourage people those who are some like
you were a typical Christian who now
they are seeing the proof and evidence
that Islam provides that it is indeed
the true from the one creator we simply
I mean explaining Islam simply means to
acquire peace by submitting your will to
the owner if he's the one gasps so
they're like what we have to say and
they're stimulated by such intellectuals
like yourself who are coming to Islam
and now but you know what there's some
hype out there they get some
misinformation just giving them some
some motivation now they again
again to the Dean Shaw and here they're
hearing opposite of you know a mean God
a vengeful God to would we're giving the
evidence this is a merciful and loving
God another lightning factor what what
motivation our encouragement do you give
for those some of the atypical
Christians that are out there like you
were who don't believe in the Trinity
who don't believe in the you know the
death of God on the cross and you know
they had this stumbling block because
they thought you know law was there's no
love in the crown or none of these two
but now they're hearing otherwise well
one thing I would encourage them to do
is go to the source to finding out about
Islam in other words pick up a good and
I want to emphasize this a good reliable
translation of the Quran and begin
reading it see for yourself
exactly what it said they're the same
way okay if you're going to go ahead and
you want the best car that's out on the
market go to Consumer Reports you're
going to put everything together you
know investigate compare so do some leg
work the same way you would do it for
any material thing absolutely yeah okay
well we're gonna look forward to it God
willing doing some more programs you
know but thank you for being with us
we'll see you soon again and thank you
for tuning again into another episode of
the Deen show you got to learn that
Islam I shall love all mankind
Islam is there and it's a way of life
that God Almighty the creator sent
through his last and final message and
all the messengers of God they all
taught Islam and they all taught that
the crater is the most loving the most
merciful and he is there but the
question is are you ready to accept the
way of life that he wants you to live
there's accountability if you do bad
even if you've done so much up to the
heavens and the earth and you haven't
set up a God next to God even if you did
that God is still ready to accept your
repentance he is still ready to turn to
you with the most loving and merciful
attribute that he has but it's up to you
now to change in mend your ways it's up
to you to
decide within yourself to live a
righteous and good wholesome life and
then turn to the most loving the most
merciful and ask him for the guidance
and then things will be made clear and
we'll see you next time keep tuning in
here to the Deen show until then peace
be unto you